[拍手]
相手は先納品とまったーーーということでどういう
同友会がのかそんなことよく知らないんですけど
高校生に向けて
値が設定していた
テーマでは
ので短い時間
けど鬱
でなかなかですねー
一つの学年意外とが一つの
ない機会で
初戦のテーマに沿って話にしても
生徒たちの幅はけっこう広いなーって思って上話をしてあげたらいい
でそれって考えたときにウェンは卒業アルバムなんですけど
27切っていく
でへ
食用油の一番下のページに余白があって
卒業生たちは卒業アルバムができると
初見やってきて
5お願いしまーすなというふうに
コメント貰えるはページが
そういった生徒たちが僕の方に来た時にいい
まあ書いてあげている言葉を思い出してちょうどそれが
テーマにも伝わるんじゃないかな
持って a
でまぁ国語の先生とか
な先生宅いい言葉を改定
けどそんな言葉が書けないので
いつもですねー
このページ
嫌いなものパワー
合併
サーフィンロボに終わって
電波って書いてあげている
でそれを思い出してあーこれを今回の格好の外へというのを生徒会の子達が
上田テーマなんですけど考えるときにその前にちょっとみんなに共有して欲しいなぁと
思っ
なのでこれは生まで好きなこと全力でということを少しだけ短い時間ですけど
話させてもこれと思いますので
足を聞いてもらえればと思います
さて大前提なんですけど seiko セイコーは一番不安なんですけど
好きなこと俺はアルティスとてあげてくる
青以上いますね
ここが仲間をが11時ぐらいからみんなタッチちょい子達からね
ブービーいくれていっ悪さティっは
まあ市名古山みたいに取れてほしいなと
けど
えっからちょっと見えるか分からないですけど行くカーっても個人個人が設定するもの
なので
ランプあってもいいと思いますしでは高さとかきました
あー登りやすいとか途中でやめるとかそういうのを自分で決めていいと思うんですけど
そういうふうにこれが好きなとかということを
まずもってほしいなっていうふうに思いますかすごく強く
でそういうふうにするとなんでや待っていた
言うのそれをまあ長さにかかわらず
ケアしさにかかわらず電力年の発表し
って言うよね
でじゃないで全力かっていうと好きなものだから絶対の方できることができると思う
から
そういう意味で改めてね今日は多分この後 o
ま先生たちとか同級生先輩たちが
非常に意識が高い子達
ことで頑張っているというようなプレゼンです
てると思うので
今でもし式な言葉お前わからないとかないという人がいた場合は
参考になるに機械じゃないか
スタートしてこういう投げかけを多く
そして君たちがよしじゃあそれする
好きなものについて考えた頑張っているところ
you
中東にいいかなっていう
今といってもですね具体的にじゃあ女っていうの本当に全部の願って
数が白人が
あげないんですけど様々な僕が
あのー生徒と一緒にねえ
これ
見た事がありますか
雨ラスカイって言っていろんなね最近のコマちょこ氏のアートねぇどこ
にかけるもしかしたら見たことあるとき
けどで装飾部分もね西高山に向かって
子達が
これをやりたいっていうふうに相談しましたで実はでもおめでとうその相談が来るのは
3回目か4回目ぐらいなんですよ
3名を年目という
だけど非常に実はこれ見た目とてもきれいなんですけど
後方生や中学生のアイディアと力でこれを成立させまってすごく
厳しい条件をつけるとやっぱりやめますとか
途中であきらめるということがすごく多かったんですけど今年のチームの子たちは
数
今が余っていてそうやって厳しく言ったのか分からず
終わって着々と準備ようで
お伝えしています
まあみんなも
学校の勉強といえば教室の中で見たことないような細胞が
付いていると思うんですけど様々なごぼう仕上げています
減るはずの笠岡
傘がコーラボタンとかね
大変なんですけどでこういうことをしながら
今ですね
ここまでこぎつけました
だけど
で
実は見えてる部分はまずが並んで綺麗なんですけど今一番の課題は両端をどうやって
引っ張って今絡んでるのまっすぐにするかどうか
じゃあすごい重さや力で引っ張った元建て求めるかということを
校舎を壊さなかったり
人の安全とかを踏まえながら一生懸命考えていかなきゃいけないという状況なんですね
で現場頑張っているので実験は一緒にも付き合ってますけどまだ成功歳でしたい人が
いっぱい来るかもしれないのに
どういけるようやっていいよ学校にも過去のライン方っていう状況には僕はッ
なんてないと思っています
だけどこれは9月までの間に
また数は当然ですけど
早めて彼らがクリアできれば
こういった中には同館がもし数とする
かもしれない
言えないかもしれんだけどやることがねすごい大事なものなので
まあとても面白いことを言いましてうれしい
充実感あるんじゃないかなぁと思っを持っていることがこういったことです
もう1本の直前デー
番外編なっているこれを自分の大学生という感じなんですけど
あのー
政府前割りと普通の学校に比べると台が遠くなってきたら
は自由に
カフェにあっていいよーっていうのは普通になって
君たちも学校休んだいきたい
使われたいという授業の時間のはこのないような生活
いるとすごく楽しい学校なるかな
ですけど僕自身がですね
大学選択に
まこ同時に参りたいので何でも見たり良い体験したいできますけど集合住宅なんです
けど中国である
世界遺産が写真を見たりしたときに
なんだこれ思えない
ますじゃないかなと
てこういうのは一生懸命1回見るなっ
フォアクッションでいるのです中で
で実際行ってみたいという気持ちが当時本当に情報がこんなちっちゃい雑誌の写真とか
しかないような時代だ
行かなきゃわかんない情報
でこれとかもこれアンジェリアのだ
を超えましたかもやっぱり行ってみたいなっていうふうにしてタクシー1回
どんどんや
でその時のちょっと面白いというか辺でこの話を
uk たいというだけですけど
午後は今待とうぜ
皆がやっほぉ
エゴグラムはどこにいたかっていると聖光学院くれたをいただいている
普通
ここまでっ
聞いてみましたなっていたかというとさっきも見たい
いろんな画像見ていく中で
このまあ mogu ビーズの先生なんで治し方を好きな
本当にこんなもんかってなって思うよね
実際見たいというふうに思い
これを見てあると思うわけですけどまぁ上から下がらず差額の南かなって
大変だったんですね
石川5歳馬写真が
その空気に川に水がたまってくれたあそこまで行けないですよ
で
高校1年生にはビーチの時間に満ちてあげたんですけどこの旅の途中 no 僕の一番
謎の状態はですね
状態になるんですねわかりません
でこの人が成長です
同じ多分鄭州です
この人とここから鑑賞するから
いいけどもいろいろに行けとかして
が船長の息子で
このが一番良識学校は対応してた人で
雨季の間動かない荷物を全部積んでいるので実は動き出した直後にこれが重すぎて
ボート無理伺って
言われでまあそんなことがあったりするんですけど
f はちょっと雑談でい
けども
活動
みんなにもねその好きな事に対してどうやったら
とか何をしたら実現するかって
考えていかなきゃいけないそこが一番難しくて楽しいところだと思う
けどそれを是非で頑張ってほしいなっていうふうに思います
それをやったり成し遂げたりしている最中だったり終わった後の自分が一番これこう
いうことができるとかやってみたっていうふうに人に1億いる
6色まで来てくださって
と思うんですね是非ご覧してほしい
でそういう風にして初めて外に向かって発信するっていうことができるような自分が
ないのに
外に向かって発信するのでちょっと不安だしもしかしは外に負けちゃうかもしれない
それはちょっと良くないだろうと言う
でそれができるようなとこうやって前の人たちからの
ねぇねぇあれこういうのどうなっているのと買って帰られたりとか
が受信する側になってこうコミュニケーションを始まると思います
それがしっかりできるようなで初めて
これは書いてないんですけど
内側と外側っていうのは自分の中で自覚した状態で
できるんじゃないかなと言う
これを頑張って行けば
繰り返して繰り返してるんですとー
自分の中で傾向とかあ俺ってこういうの好きなんだ本に興味あったら
しっかりとしてもになってそれはそれ自身も
で伝えられるような個性言われるものが生まれてくるんじゃないかなと思うので是非お
山をたくさん見つけてですね
その山を暴力繰り返しやっていけば絶対に外に向かって発信できる力が
強くなっているんじゃないか
なっていうふうに
なのでまぁテーマですかねそこに以上ですかっこいいんじゃないですね
格好の外へということをテーマにお願いしますという風に
ですけどがこのトップバッターでスタート話を
あたってはあ
まずね内側過去の中に自分というところをしっかり強く
う
うっていくという意識を持つというのが特に
西高の生徒は実は持ってねー
例のそれを自身を受けたいとか人に伝えたりとか
いるところをちょっとブレーキを上げてあったりする
が多いのかなと思うのでそういうふうにならなくて済むぐらい自身が出るように
興味のあること
好きなことを全力でやってくれるって言うのが
とても大切なこと
ので強化しよう
旅行も終わりになりますけど簡単に行くことがする方ですよね
好きな元全力で小学生トラベル待つしか使ってない
ところが全力っていうのは実はすごく難しくて
で終わりの話
まあみんなも想像していろんな力だと思います
それは巻き込む力だったり失敗を掘れない地下あり
応援してもらえる力するのは僕だったと思う
みっ
全力でやったらどういうことを合法
っていう風にしたときにイメージする力こういう力と思うんですけど
ただし鳥山頑張ってもっていうか全力じゃなくて
こういった部分僕だねみんなもしかしたら違う設定かもしれないけどこういうところを
意識しながら全力でやっていくと
絶対達成できる牛山に上れる思うので
そういったことをちょっと心を含めて今日この後の
様々な話を
意気込んで理解しながら
ジャパで追った
ありがとうございました
[拍手]